je vous remercie de reprendre cette
question sur le premier à la
bronchiolite et à nos hôpitaux vous
savez que ça me préoccupe
particulièrement mais je veux apporter
quelques précisions dans ce que je peux
entendre
non on ne trie pas les enfants à
l'entrée de l'hôpital les monts un sens
celui-ci c'est ajouter artificiellement
de l'inquiétude de l'angoisse aux
parents ça peut même être plus dangereux
que ça en poussant à du renoncement aux
soins donc je le redis avec force notre
système de santé prend en charge tous
les enfants en situation de détresse
système de santé dans son ensemble et il
le prend en charge dans des parcours de
soins
identifiés pour répondre aux besoins je
le redis toutes les bronchiolites ne
doivent pas aller à l'hôpital
[Musique]